oh hey good to see you thanks for having
us this is my girlfriend we're so happy
you could join us this is my wife so
this is the infamous and has told me so
much about you both good things I hope
you could never trust please please
don't call me makes me think my mother's
around someplace where is little oh
she's that house for a slumber party
there was this a couple from New York
that we wanted you guys to meet this is
and her husband they're gonna be in New
York for a few weeks so we were hoping
you could give them some tips oh I'm
sure I'll be great so how do you know
and oh well and I went to school of
Dramatic Arts back when I was working in
Midtown hmm oh where did you work I was
at uh and the law firm good to see you
everybody this is I want you to meet one
of my dearest oldest friends this is his
girlfriend of course you know this is
and this is her husband what a beautiful
name you know I knew uh in grad school
oh well thank you but it's actually
pronounced Wow I swear that sounds like
what you were saying anyways it's lovely
to meet you all Robert I'm so sorry
Henryk
show myself to the restroom
o4c
you